hey YouTubers it's Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Doctor Who Q&A hopefully you
guys have had a chance to see the
special by now and happy holidays to
everyone whether or not you celebrate
Christmas just as a quick update there
was some news announced right after the
special aired Jenna Colman has signed on
supposedly for all of series 9 as far as
we know it's going to be for all of
series 9 for those that haven't seen the
Christmas special there was just a spot
at the end where they did the Lord of
the Rings Return at the king type thing
where they had a couple different
endings or moments that felt like they
could have been endings until the story
continued I'll get into that a little
bit more during the questions but Moffet
has said that there are three stories so
far that he's finished for series 9 the
first one being The Magician's
Apprentice I've heard that they will be
shooting at the end of January or by the
end of January so if you're near Cardiff
just go camp the set and post pictures
so we can find out what's going on your
assistance is greatly appreciated by all
of Doctor Who fandom all over the world
oh and one more thing I wanted to add a
lot of you pointed this out in the
comments the song merry Christmas
everybody the one that Shona was jamming
out to that was actually the same song
Mickey was listening to in his garage
during the Christmas Invasion during
David tenant's first episode it's been a
long time since I've actually seen that
episode so thank you guys for pointing
that out so let's answer some questions
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet but starting
with question number one Gian X Mash
asks in the Christmas carol episode the
doctor explains that he and Santa know
each other I don't know if I paid
attention but is this episode apply
implying that Santa isn't real that he's
a figment of the imagination to help
them escape the dreams I think that they
were playing on that yes the doctor has
referenced Santa in the past like he's
said to others that he has met Santa a
lot of people complain that mfet breaks
continuity from Classico so it depends
on how you feel about moffett's logic in
this episode if you're just going based
on this episode they're suggesting that
he's a real person that's what the
Tangerine at the end was meant to imply
or at least to cast doubt that he was
completely fictitious because if the
doctor and claraa hadn't left that
Tangerine there who did he actually
compared himself to Gmail I thought that
was really funny or email in general
he's like have you ever wondered how
email gets in your inbox same thing the
funny thing about Nick Frost during the
episode though is that he contradicts
himself like he tries to prove that he
is not Santa and then later he tries to
prove that he's Santa so he actually
tries to do it both ways it's really
funny I don't think it's a logic problem
or something in the writing I think it's
Santa just messing with claraa question
number two Matt dusco asks was this
written to possibly be Jenna's last
episode seemed entirely possible that
the older version of her could have been
the last time we see her yeah I mean
like I said that scene where the doctor
looks at her and she's old then the
camera pans away and he says you'll
always look the same to me pans back and
it's young claraa again in the original
version if she had a left I think that
they would have had their final parting
of ways and she would have been like
look at all these Adventures I went on I
had a happy life I'm very happy with the
way things went down in this version
though the doctor is like oh this is
another dream then wakes up again comes
back to real claraa and then they go on
there Adventures again for series 9 so
it was just a Lord of the Rings thing
where they have like all these different
logical end points and you're like okay
clearly they originally meant to end
here but ended up just going a little
step further because Jenna Coleman
decided to stay question number three
Tobias K asks I have a question
shouldn't Clara be pregnant that's a
good question I mean we met her and
Danny's grandson in listen and by the
way merry Christmas happy holidays well
thank you merry Christmas happy holidays
to you to so mafit explained that Orson
pink was a distant relative of Danny
pink wasn't a direct grandson was like a
sister of Brothers you could look at it
a couple of different ways you could say
yes this is just another relative that
just happens to look exactly like Danny
pink but isn't directly related to him
it's just like a cousin a distant cousin
or you could say you know maybe at one
point when mfet was writing this story
or when they were working on the story I
don't know that Moffet wrote that
episode particularly they wanted to
suggest that claraa and Dany might have
a child when I was watching the episode
that's actually what I thought about I
thought they were just teasing Clara
with the idea that she would get married
to Danny pink and they would have
children if they had have known ahead of
time that clar was going to stay on for
series 9 I do wonder if Danny pink would
have stayed on for series 92 if they
would have not killed him off that's
actually a really good question I do
feel like they would have kept him on it
would have been an aor situation but
since they' done that so recently they
might have been trying to do something
different so it's possible that they
were going to kill him off no matter
what question number four Vons basil
asks do you think that River will be
back for series 9 at least one or two
episodes maet also said that he was
totally open to Bringing River Song back
which I thought was interesting because
I think before he had said that he
wasn't going to do that everybody's
always flip-flopping behind the scenes
on Doctor Who yes we want to do this no
we don't want to do that I think most
recently in the most recent interview I
read he said he did have an idea for how
to bring her back but he said he really
did like her ending in the series 7
finale I think logically what he was
pointing to is that River said that she
had met older versions of the doctor I
think that Kali could be one of those
older versions given his stance on r
Rance I guess it would be a new spin on
their relationship but because they age
in different directions it'd be a much
younger version of river that we'd be
meeting question number five the huan
network asks do you think that Santa
slay is a Tardis when Santa says it's
bigger on the inside do you think that
Santa is a time lord and we'll see him
again in series 9 so I don't I don't
think that we're going to see Nick Frost
as Santa again I think there'll be jokes
about Santa he'll definitely reference
him the Santa that we were seeing Inside
the episode was the dream Santa so they
just created those things
I think because Capaldi was in there
because the doctor was in the dream he
had qualities of a Time Lord question
number six Hydra de little asks why is
nobody bothered by the fact that there
are dream crabs still on Earth is that
supposed to be okay nobody going to take
care of those that's a good question I
think that at a certain point the doctor
probably took care of those after the
fact it is a bit of a plot hole it's not
addressed I mean that happens every once
in a while I think we're just meant to
think that eventually the problem took
care of itself which isn't an answer I
know that's not a real answer
realistically though whenever you ask
questions of writers or people like MAF
when you ask them questions like this
they usually imply TV rules where they
asked the fandom to give them certain
Liberties in storytelling if it had been
a book like if this had been a book we
were reading they could have just
written an extra 10 pages to explain it
but because it's TV they have limited
time what they can show they just
decided not to address it maybe that
maybe that's what clar and his Adventure
was right after they took off they they
okay well we saved ourselves now we got
to go save everyone else they had to go
visit the other people the sleigh to
make sure that they weren't also in a
dream inside a dream inside a dream
still I like the idea of that though
Shona is still in a dream watching her
Game of Thrones Marathon question number
seven Matthew maen asks do you think the
page numbers Clara chose meant anything
and personal question did you get any do
who goodies for Christmas so to answer
your first question I think um the page
number it was really just number 12
because Capal being the 12th doctor if
you remember in series 7 episode one to
the child like one of her boards that
she was taking care of had the book she
said chapter 11 was the best because it
was the Matt Smith Doctor in that
episode and to answer your second
question I didn't really get any doctor
hug goodies but I did get a new
microphone see if I can show you guys
it's like right here yay so I'm really
happy about that that's fin only Dr hug
goody I put like a little blue ball on
top of it question number eight grenette
asks does the doctor have a catch word
or catchphrase like alany or gono seems
to me he says shut up and do as you're
told a lot yeah I mean if he had a cat
phrase it would definitely be shut up or
shuted up whenever Capal leaves that's
definitely what people are going to
remember unless something else even
crazier comes along officially I don't
think he has a catchphrase I think that
they're not doing catchphrases but that
doesn't mean he doesn't have one it just
means that there's not one that the BBC
is promoting question number nine
Charlie blacket asks when everyone woke
up after being on Santa's sleigh it
turned out to still be a dream with
claraa being old does that mean that the
other four characters are also still
dreaming and therefore dead or possibly
never existed at all that's actually an
interesting thought the fact that they
maybe they never existed I don't think
it was just the doctor and claraa but as
cold as the doctor was I do think that
he tried to make sure that the dream
crabs were taken care of that the
problem was taken care of you can look
at that as another plot hole it's like
the Robin Hood thing you know does the
doctor care after the fact whether or
not Robin Hood is really real or does he
just fly away in his Tardis question
number 10 Gabriel Bo asks what do you
think is going to be the main story arc
of series 9 I'm hoping that the doctor
goes looking for Gala Fray I don't know
if they're necessarily going to do that
I think that the final moment like in
the finale when he looked for it and
didn't find it it was like Moffet saying
we're not going to be going here anytime
soon before series 8 had started I was
really hoping they were going to follow
up on the long way round line that Matt
Smith had I do think that Gala Fray the
idea of galif fray and the time Lords
will be involved in series 9 it might
just not necessarily be the main plot
but if the master or the mistress or
however you want to think about her is
coming back and she knows where galif
Fray is is and I do think that she does
know even though she lied about where it
was they will have to follow up on that
at some point which is actually a good
question because do you think that the
mistress or the master coming back was
the overarching plot of series 8 it
seemed like they wanted it to be but
because of the disjointed way in which
they told her story over those Eight
Episodes or really she was only in about
half of those episodes it felt like she
just kind of came in at the end in the
real overarching story like the biggest
story with just learning who this new
doctor was and what his relationships
with everyone was going to be so many
things that you could argue with your
friends about you know what was series 8
really about was it about the mistress
or was it about the new doctor or
something else completely so thank you
everyone for submitting questions these
are always a ton of fun to do and just a
quick heads up I doubled the giveaway
just because it's the holidays and I
wanted to be nice so congratulations to
Josh Hoskins and Sylvia major just be
sure to message me on my channel for
contact details so I can get your
contact info my next Doctor Who bonus
video should post in the next couple of
days I'm going to try and mix it up a a
little bit agent Carter's coming so I
might do some Marvel videos and some
other stuff be sure to subscribe to get
everything people in the UK I've heard
that channel 4 is not going to air Agent
Carter it premieres in the United States
on January 6th on Tuesday so I'll try to
find some information about where
International people can watch the show
but if you do have any information about
that just post it in the comments below
right now if you're on your mobile phone
or on your tablet there's new mobile
links you can click on up here it's the
same as the links over here click here
for my Christmas special video and click
here for all my other doctor who bonus
videos thank you so much for watching so
let's all high five happy holidays I
will see you guys
tonight